They're the most dangerous extreme weather
phenomena.
Heat waves basically affect our bodies and
the ecosystems around us, and they send us
to the hospital or they kill us.
This is Europe's first Chief Heat Officer.
Her task is to find ways to protect citizens
from the dangerous effects of extreme heat.
As the climate warms and the frequency of
heat waves dramatically increases, cities
are appointing people like her to limit the
dangers.
We talked to three of them to find out how
we can best deal with this new normal.
What's coming our way and what can we do to
protect ourselves?
I started thinking of what I have to do in
three pillars.
The first pillar has to do with raising awareness.
How do we communicate and get people to take
this seriously?
Many of us aren't aware of just how dangerous
heat can be because heat is a silent killer
– we don't see the effects of extreme heat
as visibly as the physical destruction brought
by hurricanes, floods and other natural disasters.
But extreme heat now kills up to half a million
people worldwide each year - that's more than
all other natural disasters that aren't due
to the temperature.
And the problem is getting worse, especially
in cities, which are heating up at twice the
global average rate because they trap heat
more than non-urban areas.
This is going to be one of the coolest summers
that we're going to have for the rest of our
lives.
And that's not something that we should take
lightly.
We really have to understand that cities are
really hotspots.They're not going to be able
to be viable in a few decades.
By 2100, cities across the world could warm
as much as 4.4°C on average.
So how do officials best sound the alarm and
make sure people understand the gravity of
the situation?
One of the things that was done for raising
awareness, which I think is really a game
changer, we have been categorizing heat waves
for the first time in Athens this year.
It's a pilot project that was started in Seville,
Spain and Athens, Greece and will be adopted
by other cities soon.
It categorizes heat waves based on their effect
on human health – much like earthquakes
get categorized based on their intensity.
The idea is to help people prepare and respond
better.
And that's not all.
Heat waves will also be named in the future.
Just like Hurricane Katrina immediately evokes
these images in your head and makes it easier
to remember the disaster, so may Heat Wave
Zoe – the world’s first-ever heat event
to officially be named in Seville at the end
of July.
Once it's clear that a heat wave is especially
dangerous, information on how to stay safe
can be spread to those who are most endangered.
Messaging around heat waves is really critical
because there's a lot people can do with their
own behavior to keep them safer.
The city of Athens even developed an extreme
heat app that's now also being used in Milan,
Paris and Rotterdam.
We have an application called Extrema Global
that shows you your personalized risk, depending
where you are in the city and your age and
your gender and whether you have preexisting
conditions.
And it also tells you on the map where to
go to take cover, where the cool spots are
around you.
In a similar effort, Africa's first heat officer
is currently creating a heat map for the city
of Freetown.
What we're trying to do is to understand where
are the hotspots, where are the urban heat
islands to better plan and prioritize resources.
Resources in Sierra Leone are limited, so
Eugenia Kargbo wants to focus on helping the
most vulnerable people first.
That includes female vendors who are exposed
to the sun all day when selling their produce
in uncovered markets without any shade.
So what we've done is to work together with
those women and design a project which we
call the market shade cover project.
Basically it's a simple design.
We use material that is heat reflective, that
doesn't absorb the heat to provide a shade
cover for the women.
The project will be implemented and launched
within the next few months.
Just even seeing the joy on their face when
I was talking to them about the project gave
me hope that definitely there's something
that can be done to help save lives and help
improve the living condition of people who
are the most vulnerable.
On a larger scale, the design of entire cities
can evolve to beat the heat.
One of the solutions that Athens has been
trying to implement, which a lot of cities
have tried to implement around the world,
is creating green corridors.
And we have finalized the designs of three
green corridors in Athens.
Meanwhile, Freetown is currently cleaning
up garbage sites and converting them into
public gardens that are clean, safe and cool.
They are also planting a million trees across
the city so that Freetown eventually becomes
Tree-town.
Santiago de Chile is taking a similar approach.
We just funded a $2 million urban forest program.
It's a really ambitious initiative that aims
to provide at least 30,000 trees for the city.
We never had that in the past before.
Trees don't just provide shade and reflect
the sun's rays back up.
They also help lower the air temperature around
them by essentially sweating.
They take up water from the ground, which
then gets put back into the air through a
process called evapotranspiration.
But they aren't the only form of vegetation
that can help cool down the air.
In places where there might not be enough
space for new trees, streets and roofs can
also be greened.
Cities across the world, from Paris to London,
Bangkok to Singapore, have started incorporating
green roofs or living walls in their urban
architecture.
And Santiago de Chile is looking to do the
same.
They are about to start building a cool roof
on a public building.
We know that green roofs can provide many
benefits like cooling down the buildings,
saving energy, but also helping people to
look at some green.
It can help with their mental health and also
provide a little biodiversity within the city.
So we are doing the first one in September
and the idea is to measure everything in order
to scale that project to the rest of the city
in the near future.
Experts believe cities also have to change
the way they construct new buildings to adapt
to the heat in the future.
Our cities are built primarily with materials
that absorb solar energy, that are impermeable
to water, so we don't get the sort of evaporative
benefits, and so we've basically designed
our cities to trap heat, and that's what they're
doing.
Using nature-based materials with high solar
reflectance is one idea.
Another is going back to using light-colored
materials for the outside of buildings – from
walls to roofs – something that southern
Europe has been doing for a long time.
And now other cities across the globe can
adapt that idea.
We have a lot of informal communities, people
who live in houses built from zinc.
So maybe that's a starting point.
Seeing how we can provide white paint.
It's kind of a basic solution, but the impact
is immense.
Of course climate change caused by carbon
emissions is the real driver of extreme heat.
We have to drastically cut our greenhouse
gas emissions in order to prevent a catastrophic
level of global warming.
But experts say that even then, so much damage
has already been done that we’ll also have
to learn to adapt.
Projections show that things are only getting
worse from here.
That's why we are addressing the problem now
in order to prepare us for the future.
We know that preparedness takes time and we
don't need to wait until a disaster or a heat
wave hits us in the face in order to prepare
for that.
The good news is, there's a lot we can do
and we have it at our fingertips.
This is less an innovation problem and more
of an adoption problem, and that means we
can do something quickly about it if we put
our minds to it.